en un reinicio de las relaciones entre
Brasil y China después de cuatro años de
relativo aislamiento internacional con
el expresidente Jair bolsonaro el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
tiene un objetivo claro fortalecer el
vínculo ya profundo entre Brasilia y
Beijing China es el principal socio
comercial de Brasil y un importante
mercado para la soja el mineral de
hierro y el petróleo Brasil es también
el mayor receptor de inversión china en
América Latina durante su visita de
estado el presidente Lula también tiene
un segundo objetivo reactivar la alianza
bricks una agrupación de las principales
economías de Mercado emergentes del
mundo compuesta por Brasil Rusia India
China y Sudáfrica una idea que Beijing
parece ver con buenos ojos
china está dispuesta a trabajar con
Brasil para utilizar Esta visita como
una oportunidad para promover una
cooperación mutuamente beneficiosa y
amistosa entre los países en desarrollo
y para abordar juntos los desafíos
globales
se espera también que Lula asista a la
toma de posesión de la expresidenta
Dilma hussef como directora del banco de
desarrollo brix el cual Busca la
creación de una moneda común que permita
a los socios comerciales evitar el uso
del dólar a finales de marzo China y
Brasil anunciaron un acuerdo para
comerciar entre sí sus monedas
nacionales Lula tenía previsto viajar a
Beijing en ese momento pero el opus puso
debido a una enfermedad sin embargo
envió parte de su delegación compuesta
por representantes del gobierno y
empresas privadas Allí se concluyeron
más de 20 acuerdos comerciales en varios
sectores
también sobre la mesa que Brasil se una
a la iniciativa de la nueva ruta de la
seda un gigantesco proyecto de inversión
china que a Beijing le gustaría extender
aún más en América del Sur